dans son témoignage mais se battre c'est
revenu en détail sur le remaniement
ministériel qui a mené au déplacement de
joey worthen web horde vers les anciens
combattants il a insisté pour dire que
celle ci ne faisait pas partie des
facteurs pris en considération et selon
lui le plan du premier ministre trudeau
était de nommer john philpot au conseil
du trésor en remplacement de scop
personne qui vient de partir de quitter
la vie politique est de donner à la
ministre la justice de l'époque jean
diwo à ce niveau le ministère des
services aux autochtones tout ça pour
envoyer signale que ce ministère était
prioritaire à ses yeux il n'avait pas
prévu que madame oleson billboard
refuserait ce poste j'en parle avec le
grand chef de la nation huronne wendat
monsieur si oui bonsoir oui même à
mosman alors aux yeux monsieur on a
entendu monsieur boss témoigne l effet
que pour l administrer ce ministère des
services aux autochtones s'était
appliqué une loi qu'elle a honni toute
sa vie la loi sur les indiens est ce que
vous comprenez la décision de madame
boissons mais bon si ce que dit monsieur
bats aimerait évidemment moi ce que
monsieur bottes dit c'est vrai c'est
vrai pour nous tous la loi sur les
indiens
bon je pense que c'est fait consensus on
veut tous éventuellement moitié les zi
he et sa défaire par contre on est dans
un exercice qui est extrêmement
important présentement et cet exercice
là d'abord ça a été menée au loup du
comité le plus gros comité jamais mis en
place par monsieur trudeau depuis la
commission royale de 96
un comité pour avoir toute la question
des lois b dere de l'âme accepte les
copeaux mère nations entre autres alors
madame oleson est parti
ne sont de son propre chef on a voulu
nous jouerons certainement qu'elle
puisse prendre la responsabilité des
affaires autochtones bien sûr parce que
on voit que peut-être que de l'intérieur
on peut peut-être agir encore mieux que
d'extérieur en d'autres mots si c'est
pour ça qu'elle a refusé le poste
vous trouvez que ce n'est pas une bonne
raison qu'il fallait mieux au contraire
prendre le poste pour mieux changer les
choses données beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup comme notos aussi pour trouver
des façons de sortir du colonialisme de
trouver des manières de vie améliorée
d'autodétermination des premières
nations est là s'est dévoué s'est dédié
comme nous tous aussi mais elle fait
partie d'un gouvernement le grand
monsieur trudeau qui n'a pas d'égal au
niveau par exemple de la mise en oeuvre
des politiques et des éléments qui font
que
on s'envoie vers une une réelle autorité
remis nation on va sortir il faut
vraiment aller il faut sortir de la
victimisation faut sortir du processus
de ealing puis je commençais à être être
maîtres de notre propre destinée
un gouvernement qui vous dit une grande
sensibilité à la cause autochtone qui a
l'air de vouloir changer les choses mais
qui en même temps est ce qu'il n'a pas
commis justement une erreur de jugement
en n'ayant pas vu qu'elle pouvait
refuser ce poste précisément parce
qu'elle se retrouvait appliquer une loi
qu'elle n'aimait pas le seul je pense a
presque fait un mea culpa la tude il a
dit qu'il aurait dû voir ça ils auraient
dû vous avez
probablement que madame madame oleson
nom n'a pas réalisé qu'elle aurait
remplacé sa collègue jane ou un gin fizz
pattes qui elle aussi a démissionné il
ya 2 e deux paliers ou au secret service
auto canada aux affaires indiennes comme
on s'y attendait pas l'exécutif c'est à
dire madame madame bennett qui s'occupe
plus des politiques d traiter des
dossiers constitutionnel d ea pression
de l'eau palier qui est un pari
d'opération des programmes les services
alors l arabe certainement rappelé un
rôle important mais ça c'est sa décision
vous devez être un peu déchiré non
entendre la version d'un gouvernement
qui essaie de défendre des emplois dit
il à tout prix mais aussi la cause
autochtone qui vous venez de rappeler
tous ses faits d'armes en la matière et
une ministre la première ministre
autochtones et un portefeuille immense
qu'est celui de la justice
oui vous est déchiré entre les deux
versions non mais pour nous aussi posé
plein de questions les déchirures ou pau
madame oleson johnny c'est notre ami on
va toujours là prêt si elle est retenue
avec nos jours j'ai travaillé avec sont
pas belles
j'ai communiqué avec sa grand mère à
l'époque des lettres qu'on s'échange
essais des personnes exceptionnelles
mais en même temps on est dans un
exercice extrêmement important il n'y a
pas un gouvernement à date et s'offre le
reconnaître qu'il ya mieux tant
d'efforts pour les premières nations
pour les peuples autochtones qui meurent
qui m'a afin qu'aucune machine nous
permettant les marques des montants
d'argent aussi reconnaissons ne pourra
qu après midi rue notre sort alors de ce
côté-là nous autres on est en héros est
en mouvement et un élan qui dispose lui
c'était là ne faut pas le faux pas de
l'arrêter mon quoi que ce soit est ce
que vous estimez que la démission de
john wilson met ball qui a quand même
pas voulu affirmer sa confiance dans le
premier ministre trudeau dans ce
gouvernement
est-ce que ça affecte pas justement
l'image d'un gouvernement libéral que
juger par ce que vous dites vous
souhaiteriez voir élire et lui même mais
est-ce que ça n'affecte pas justement
son image bien gardé ses c'est toujours
triste de voir des partenaires
les gens qui au caire on a tellement
fait confiance pied auquel on s'est
associés aussi dans cette démarche là de
voir que ça arrive des situations comme
ça personne soit ça alors nous de notre
côté
bien sûr qu'on veut voir essentiel à
varen continue d'opérer bien ce qu'on
veut voir d'élise les gens allaient
gagner gagner leur vie
il ya depuis que ces emplois soient
protégés et bien sûr qu'on veut on veut
le meilleur pour notre canada pour notre
québec pour notre nos premières nations
mais à travers ça on reste concentrés
sur nos objectifs c'est à dire améliorer
notre sort se donner ou redonner les
outils parce que le temps va vite aussi
et on vit dans un monde très incertain
alors les premières nations le besoin
d'être appuyé puis de ce côté là c'est
certain que je regarde pas en arrière je
regarde en avant parce qu en arrière du
temps que monsieur trudeau étape à la
sapo tout l'été facile ausy que le pain
est à sec
voilà qui est dit monsieur konrad sioui
merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à
l'émission ce soir c'est au revoir